hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
a while ago i post a few
videos where i analyzed the objectively
what's inside high resolution music and
i showed a number of defects and
problems in production of high-risk
music where the extra bandwidth was used
to
basically ship us more garbage
some good came out of one of them in
that the independent label actually went
back and corrected those mistakes so
did some good this morning somebody
reached out to me and said hey how about
analyzing some of the ps i'd use
in-house label the octave recording
studio
to see
how they produce their music as you some
of you know i've been analyzing their
hardware products he was curious to see
you know do it do a good job there or
are there issues in in that as well so i
thought that was a good idea and
one on their website and uh
found out they have one album from don
grusin uh
dave grueson's brother
and it's available on lp and a bunch of
other formats we're not interested in
but luckily they by the way those other
formats are quite expensive sixty
dollars
for vinyl but luckily they have a
package download package for 29 for that
you get the dsc64 which is the native uh
format of the recording then they have
24-bit uh 192 and 24 bit 96 and 24 bit
44.1 you get them all for 29
pretty steep price uh but uh you know
compared to a album you buy in cd for 10
or 12 or stream it for free
on this thing but for high-res downloads
i say slightly overpriced i've paid
anywhere between 15 to 20 dollars for
high-risk music that i have purchased so
not too much complaining about this if
the music's good and fidelity is good
and that's what we're going to try to
examine so as i mentioned uh
this is a the file original recording is
in dst so we're going to start with the
sd
what is dsd this is called dsd64 or one
xdsd it's the original digital format
that goes on super audio cd sacd format
that came out
20 30 years ago
the format as a physical format died
more or less there's some releases still
today but you know it's not never cheap
mainstream status
but the digital version of it for
downloading has survived and people
actually now have
uh double and
quadruple rates and even higher rate
version of dst dst6 called dst 64 120 at
256 512 when the game goes on
and
to analyze the sd files i have to use
the special program the
music scope which unfortunately is not
available anymore to purchase
but anyway it's it's a tool i have for
analyzing this i'll then show you the
pcm versions uh separately so let's go
ahead and
play this jack
the track is called sunundes uh which is
uh
japanese
uh i don't know what he's called one of
his japanese rays but
there it is
so we already
can tell what's going on in here
instantly so
if you look in here we have the piano
notes playing this is the beginning of
our spectrum uh
i guess it goes down to zero hertz
and then this is 22 kilohertz which will
be the limit for cd format and then the
it's showing me up to 88 kilohertz for
this dsd file
but
you know let me play it again and pay
attention to this section
you can see that this section goes up
and down
as the notes play
but this area does not change at all
there's a technical reason for that
tst64 is a one bit format means that the
entire
the digital value is either captured as
a one and a zero that's it nothing in
between
uh well then how do you get all the
you know bit depth that we need to have
great dynamic range um
the the
that one bit system
generates a ton of noise much like if
you some of you remember uh black and
white uh newspaper uh pictures uh had
gray scales in it even though they
didn't have more than a black or white
either
but they by
but it was very very noisy that noise
can actually be what is called noise
shaped and pulled out of the audible
spectrum over here into
another spectrum mathematically and uh
that's exactly what's been done so there
was a ton of noise in here in this one
bit format that would make this
unlistenable but by noise shaping they
pulled all that noise into the
ultrasonic region
now if you buy an sacd that was such
encoded back up
i think all of sacd players had a low
pass filter where you could tell the
player once it's decoded and it's got
all this junk in here to filter out some
of this and some of them had two
switches two settings like 50 killers
and 70 killers
and none i guess um
and some of my thing only has single
switch
excuse me
um
but either way they had a roll off but
when we get this thing now as a raw
format delivered to us they gave it to
us like this and our dax don't know even
if you have a dsd dac doesn't know to
apply any filter into this so when you
play this as a digital file
the entire thing gets transmitted to
amplifier and to your
speakers and if you look at the level in
here
it is lower than the our peak over here
but it's also much higher than the
actual spectrum of music high
frequencies in here so this is
non-trivial amount of noise to be
pumping into the uh
um the speaker and amplifier the app may
oscillate the tweeter may be unhappy
or do nothing i don't know but certainly
you know
why do we want to download bunch of
noise this file was 350 megabytes for
one track
uh on this thing remember entire six cds
650 megabytes so this is half a cd for
one track
and the
bulk of what we're getting is noise and
noise unfortunately cannot be compressed
losslessly so even though they deliver
this as a zip file to us that that that
portion of it cannot be compressed or
made any smaller and that's why the
files are so big
so not a good thing
but you know this is the decision
they've made and they think the sd-64
scats me out and it's the best format
there is and that's what they're raw
recorded in that format so in my opinion
it's a mistake in this day and age
there's no reason to use this
you want to go ahead and capture in the
best format which is pcm format today
or at least use higher sample rate dsd
don't use dsd64
on this thing
so let's now switch away from uh from
this guy and bring up adobe edition um
i'm gonna shut this guy off
so uh let me bring audition up for me
all right so i've got three versions of
uh the file loaded um
first one is uh 192 kilohertz i don't
know if you can see it down here it says
kilohertz and this is 24 bit format the
next one is 96 killers and the last one
is uh 44.1 kilos or cd sample rate
so if i go play the uh first one and
bring this back
oops sorry
i told you that in reverse order
or did i
no i didn't load the uh
high sample rate bro come on
you can do it
ah shoot right into a bug
all right let me play the 96 kilo
version for you for some reason editions
got confused on the 192khz version
now this is the 96 killer sample i'm
playing let me pause it
look at what's happened we have our
piano notes over here then we have what
more or less doesn't seem to change a
whole lot and then above that we have
that massive hump that we had
with the uh
dsd file
which means that they encoded all this
junk when they converted that dsd file
into pcm and that's a mistake the
convention when you convert the sd files
to pcm is to actually apply a
software filter and get rid of this
noise because this is now inside of our
format that that we're playing and
pcm has this rectangular band within
quite a large area that is encoding
and we're now shipping you all junk this
file is even bigger than dsd file is
about 450 megabytes for one track
and oh sorry the 192 is this one's half
the size and clearly this is all
unwanted junk so let me play the rest of
it for you
you can see that the meaningful part is
really up to about 20 to 23 kilohertz
nothing above is changing it's just
static noise
and again the level is quite high the
level is as high as
what four or six kilohertz would be in
in the music
so we don't want that this shouldn't
have been there
uh if they have rolled that off
um
this file would have been smaller and
the download would have taken less time
by the way this entire package was 9
gigabyte worth of data to download so
quite big for multiple versions
so now let's go to the uh
final version they gave us which is 44.1
kilohertz 24 bit uh oftentimes this is
distributed at 16 bits you can just burn
it into a cd if you wanted to do that a
little unusual to see it in 24 bit but i
take it that's a good thing uh we don't
want them to try to uh
uh try to uh do that conversion of down
to 16 bits which they could ge
that could screw up as well
so now we see that basically the 44.1
kilohertz version
uh
it's
capturing everything we needed in this
track there was no reason to have any
more than that maybe a little bit more
so 48 kilohertz
uh would have been the uh
ideal sample rate for this that would
have captured everything we want and it
would truncate all the dsd 64 noise that
was delivered to us in our high risk
packages on this thing
so
it's a miss on multiple fronts
clearly no measurements were performed
to look at the spectrum of the file they
created i think i don't care how much
you love this format if you just looked
at the original format and and saw the
uh
let me bring that back again
um
you know you saw this thing and didn't
change any smart person would say hmm
how's this good for sound
you know why not just put a noise
generator in the player haven't spit out
noise
if if all we want to do is ship out
noise
the other thing is just the content that
they produce this is a
piano piece
is close miked
so it has basically it's kind of dry
there's no room ambience in there
and it doesn't have any of the trimmings
that i associate with audiophile music
no regular person you know they'll
actually listen to music is going to go
download and know about this high-risk
download only audio files are going to
go get them and many of them get them to
just show off their their systems and
this is just not
great sounding music that i would want
to demo any systems with it doesn't have
nice decays doesn't have room ambience
uh on this thing um i i don't know
anything about recording stuff so i
don't want to tell them how they should
record it but i do know the audience i
go to shows all the time and listen to
audio file tracks that people use to
show off system and i know the audio
file mindset of what they want to do
die in a crawl kind of you know music
and this is not it it's just that solo
piano doesn't have any high frequency
content so the notion that you want to
have high res for it doesn't play
the music itself is also uninspiring it
sounds like the kind of music that they
would have in a high-end restaurant with
somebody playing in a piano in the
corner
you know that obviously is subjective
but i don't know what you hang your hat
on as far as this the recording is is
not correct and proper it suffers from
the limitations of the st64
it's got
junk shoved into pcm converted files
um if subjective fidelity is not there
you know it's you know the music sounds
like it's in your head because the
microphones are inside or close to a
piano and
uh and the type of music is like um okay
at least diana crawl i can listen to to
the music and enjoy it as for what it is
uh until i get sick of it
but it's got some appeal
i i don't know this doesn't seem to have
anything going for it and then it's 29
so
courtesy of
me spending the 29 instead of you you
all know what the deal what the deal in
here is i don't recommend the music for
anything uh any purpose uh if you want
to do a format comparison maybe it's a
good way to to
take it although the label l2 has great
format comparison and uh
has it all different format since a free
download much better music too by the
way i'm better recorded than this stuff
so uh make a long story short uh
the
music produced by psrd is label who's a
little bit like their own products you
know mix of
good stuff and mix of buying into
folklore of thinking dst 64 is cats meow
and something's great about it and
you know we're recording wider bandwidth
and therefore something's good about it
no we're shoving bunch of noise into
people's system and uh
and if you try to play the pcm version
you're just you know carrying more noise
than content in there so
you know uh ho-hum
you know it's a pass for me
okay
hopefully learn something out of this
one if you're not interested in this
music as far as the different formats
pcm dsd and so forth
i will keep explaining these concepts in
future videos but i thought i
give you an introduction in this one
okay see you in a future video bye-bye